we need to talk
about your face or face recognition in
general
a tweet has been making the rounds
saying
facial recognition is able to analyze in
real time the emotions
and feelings
[Music]
just that and it showed a video of a
apparent real-time system looking at
people's faces
and determining what their emotions
are now there is a predictable
reaction of machine learning twitter
with respect to anything to do with
facial recognition and that reaction is
no the biggest reaction is
no this is impossible ai will
never be able to infer your emotions
by looking at your face this is the data
is not there
anything like this i just think that is
really really
really surprising honestly now look
facial recognition technology isn't
exactly the
most popular subject it's not going to
win any nobel peace prizes
anytime soon is this technology
dystopian looking
yes is it dangerous in the wrong hands
yes
does it work as advertised very probably
no is it easy to be tricked absolutely
yes however saying that it is impossible
for an
ai to look at your face and infer your
emotional
state that is
wondering me you do this every day
you look at people's faces and then you
infer
something about their internal state
people splitting hairs here about the
word analyze
to analyze the emotions and feelings
well if you want to split
words i would say inferring is a lot
heavier than
analyzing your face has literally
evolved to convey
your internal state other people have a
trouble
with saying well you can fake your face
not all facial expressions can be faked
a lot of what you tell with your face is
involuntary
and there is in principle not a reason
why a machine cannot pick up on these
cues
now this is not to say that this
particular system
works well it probably does not it is
extremely
hard to do this to look at a face and
get how that person is feeling through
all the deception
that might be there is an extremely hard
task
but there's nothing supernatural about
it we do this
we're a machine ergo a machine can in
principle
do this the most criticism i see right
here
is that well the machine only analyzes
facial expressions they have
nothing to do with your emotions and
feelings
what is that of course this has
something to do with your emotions and
feelings
have you ever thought to yourself huh
that person looks kind of sad today
have you ever gone to someone and said
you know you look a little bit down is
everything okay
no never never and you certainly didn't
infer this from their face
hey doctor i have a problem well what's
your problem well
i banged my foot and now it hurts and it
has a dent in it it bleeds and it's
swollen
and everything is bad about my foot
because i
hit it and it might be bro well don't
say it's broken
because the external symptoms will never
tell us anything about the internal
state of a system i'm sorry have you
ever heard that an ai can diagnose lung
cancer by looking at a chest
x-ray well no all we can say is just
that the ai
detects a little bit of a spot there is
no correlation
at all this is no indication of the
internal
state of the cancer
shut up twitter makes it such that
everyone
immediately is extreme on the one side
and extreme on the other side
instead of saying the data to train the
system
is very hard to get the systems itself
aren't as good they don't understand
context that this happens in or
nuances that's very different from
saying that
no this is impossible the most
ridiculous is when people come out
and compare this to phrenology or
literally call it phrenology you know
phrenology
the science of what bump on your head
means something about your personality
or intelligence
like my face has literally evolved to
tell you something about my
internal emotions none of the bumps on
my head
have evolved to communicate about my
intelligence
it is a predictable reaction for some
reason anywhere
where facial recognition technology is
used
there is a crowd of people coming out
saying phrenology
faces are a real thing emotions are a
real thing
there is a real connection between your
facial expression
and your emotions it is more complicated
than these machines
right now can assess it might require
more context more data better algorithms
and even things we don't have yet but
this definitely
exists it is not a pseudoscience not
everything that has to do
with face recognition is a pseudoscience
it might be dangerous
yet it's real so in conclusion
i guess my message here is that yes
this is probably an over promise of what
a.i
can do and it could easily be used for
bad purposes on the other hand this is
not a pseudoscience this is not
impossible
and research in this direction might
actually
lead to something good imagine an ai
that is
better than a human at recognizing
emotions
from someone's face assuming that is
possible
we could avoid a lot of conflict maybe
do a lot of good work
in suicide prevention and ultimately
communicate
with the ais as we would with other
humans apart from all the bad thing that
we can do with facial recognition
technology
ultimately its technology can be used
for good
and for bad and for evil i'll end with
the holy trifecta of broader impact
statements
technology good technology bad
technology biased
peace out
[Music]
you